So what's going on? Why isn't my face being detected?
Well, we have to look at how we give machine sight.
Computer vision uses machine learning techniques to do facial recognition.
So how this works is you create a training set with examples of faces.
This is a face, this is a face, this is not a face.
And over time, you can teach a computer how to recognize other faces.
However, if the training sets aren't really that diverse,
any face that deviates too much from the established norm will be harder to detect,
which is what was happening to me.
But don't worry, there's some good news.
Training sets don't just materialize out of nowhere.
We actually can create them.
So there's an opportunity to create full spectrum training sets
that reflect a richer portrait of humanity.
Now, you've seen it in my examples,
how social robots was how I found out about exclusion with algorithmic bias.
But algorithmic bias can also lead to discriminatory practices.
Across the US, police departments are starting to use
facial recognition software in their crime-fighting arsenal.
Georgetown Law published a report showing that one in two adults in the US,
that's 117 million people, have their faces in facial recognition networks.
Police departments can currently look at these networks unregulated
using algorithms that have not been audited for accuracy.
Yet we know facial recognition is not felt proof
and labeling faces consistently remains a challenge.
You might have seen this on Facebook.
My friends and I laugh all the time when we see other people
mislabeled in our photos.
But misidentifying a suspected criminal is no laughing matter,
nor is breaching civil liberties.
Machine learning is being used for facial recognition,
but it's also extending beyond the realm of computer vision.
In her book, Weapons of Math Destruction,
Data Scientist, Kathy O'Neill talks about the rising new WMDs.
Widespread, mysterious and destructive algorithms
that are increasingly being used to make decisions
that impact more aspects of our lives.
So who gets hired or fired?
Do you get that loan?
Do you get insurance?
Are you admitted into the college that you wanted to get into?
Do you and I pay the same price for the same product
purchased on the same platform?
Law enforcement is also starting to use machine learning
for predictive policing.
Some judges use machine-generated risk scores
to determine how long an individual is going to spend in prison.
So we really have to think about these decisions.
Are they fair?
And we've seen that algorithmic bias
doesn't necessarily always lead to fair outcomes.